my name is Sally Finkelstein Horowitz
and I come from Poland I was born in
spalling and a small town and when the
war broke out I was 11 years old and
when September 3rd the bombs came to
falling even so it was not a
industrialized city and then when the
bombers flew away
the place was uncomplete like inferno
complete and engulfed and fire and I was
scared because I couldn't get to my
parents and then after this the Germans
the planes came again and they were
spraying the people with machine guns
and then who were in the woods overnight
where we survived that then when we came
back home everything was bombed out and
we just huddled together in little rooms
with whoever we could and then there was
the ghetto who were all carted to one
place of the city and it wasn't a big
town but they still brought in from
different small towns people and
everybody was in the same place sleeping
in there whatever they could was
terrible then they were patrolling us
all the time and sometimes the Germans
would not get the doors at night and say
he's been an artist I'm a back there and
if there were girls they said they have
to inspect them they weren't doctors so
they made a little hole in the wall so
we could run out and hide and there was
also a synagogue on our town which I
cannot forget because it was the
paintings were like like on the ceiling
and they're very thick walls and the
doors were very thick and I was always
in or of that synagogue I always thought
looked a really very holy holy place
well this was burned down and when we
were in the ghetto my father and my
little brother went out to hide in a
village and I somehow did used to be in
the ghetto I just always wanted to get
out so one time I went to visit my
father that was very very close to my
father
and over sun I was sitting and I feel
like I see somebody standing this I
picked up my head and there was a man
standing there he says to me who are you
who did you come to visit because they
knew who's supposed to be in the
villages and this was a Polish man that
he was the eldest of the village and I
told my came to visit as Jewish people
so he started to yell are you Jewish I
say yes he says you wait right here he's
going to bring me to the Germans for
coming out of the ghetto and I ran
across the street I became friendly with
one of the girls they are the Polish
girls and I told her what happened and I
told I'm scared
so she said come with me and we went up
in the attic to hide in the Attic I
remember my heart was pounding so bad
and she was laughing she says don't be
scared I was scared I was the Jew so he
kept asking everybody where's that you
did anybody see that Jew where is that
Jew but nobody told him anything so the
one to look for me of course that's when
he started to scream and however I was
and then when he went away I started to
handle for my father and I was scared my
little brother was at the time about six
years old and so my father says don't
worry I would give in my battle with
vodka so he wouldn't bother you but
meanwhile I was scared now we weren't
together for a while I don't know must
have been a year or so and ah I was
horrible they were always taking us to
work and they took the outer rabbi and
they make him they made them walk on
let's say the Torah
they were pulling his beard and blood
was coming out and and then every other
day there was something else we were
sleeping in over snow we heard the
church bells and trumpets and bangs
whatever they did and you let her out
Sally even her out so we all had to get
out and meet in the marketplace and it
was a lot of shooting and a lot of
hitting and then they made us much 12
kilo meter and for some reason some a
certain person the people who stayed
with doing in the ghetto times one of
the daughters got married she was 17 or
18 she was pregnant and we were walking
the 12 kilometres and she was until I
had my own children I never thought of
her too much but I can't forget her she
was very big she must have been in the
eighth or ninth month and it was very
worn was the second days of September it
was the holidays so good the second day
after so good and she wore her father's
trench coat and my feet were very
swollen and my mother had some water she
always used to give a little bit of
water and then we came to the train
station because falling did not have a
train station at a time and we all sat
down on the ground and they were joined
we were joined by people from different
smaller cities and the others and there
were trains and back of us were all
sitting on the ground must have been
10,000 people or so and we could smell
like chlorine from the trains but we
didn't know this was going to be for us
and while we were there mice one of my
sisters
Oh few days before I was taken to
farm which was a future lemaitre's from
my hometown and I don't know for some
reason they one of the Germans was
walking by where I was sitting and he
pointed to me and I said and you know he
was looking and I got scared and my
mother made me bend down and hide myself
behind her because we didn't know what
will happen so he passed by again and he
pointed I should get up and come house
my mother pushed my other sister this
was a feel visco go you'll have to take
care of it she won't be able to wash it
here this is the last words I remember
and they took he took out about 21 women
girls then everybody started to run
everybody was sent something wrong and
there was a lot of shouldn't a lot of
meetings at the shootings and we walked
another three miles to the farm will my
sister was there and we worked there on
a potato farm and then when it got cold
there was no more potato picking they
took picked out we were a hundred people
there men and women so they picked out
again about thirty five and I was one of
them my sisters my two sisters and we
were sent to scare disco scar disco was
worse than any concentration camp you
can imagine it was an ammunition factory
and the first thing what greeted us was
people people with yellow faces they
hold they were all yellow they worked
with some chemicals or something and
they were exposed to I guess the year
whatever it was there and they were all
terribly yellow I was so frightened and
I remember and it was it was terrible
and then we were sent to a different
part and we went there more than about
two three weeks and I got very sick with
typhus we worked in a factory and I'm an
initial factor now if you stayed back
when they shot you so you had to go
every day
they used to wake us up very early in
the morning and count there was the
counting to counting the counties the
drivers crazy and then when we got to
the factory we counted and then when we
came back we were counted constantly the
counting and they had those beds like in
four four layers nostro and no nothing
and then people were getting sick and I
had Taif was very bad my hair came out
completely and there was no food
naturally they gave us a piece of bread
which wasn't bread I don't know what it
was a result of some kind it was one
time once a day and once a day we got
some soup which was like dirty water so
when we were sleeping they would they
would walk us up one time no we were
walking from work through the gates and
they hung the person in the gate so they
hung we had to look at that person for
three shifts and this wasn't too far
from the latrine ever we had to go we
had to run every night a few times
Sunday night
and he was hanging there and somebody
took off his shoes he had some shoes and
they took off his shoes they must he
must have been difficult at three four
days or more so nobody should miss him
so all this on there is no food and the
beatings I still have a scar on my leg
because we were standing and Counting
encounter that was how they decided to
hit guys over their heads and I figure
I'm not gonna get hit for nothing and I
just wanted to crawl by so I ripped my
leg with with the wire and I was
bleeding and nobody they didn't have
anything to put on my leg and it started
to spoil very bad and so when we weren't
there there was some Polish people
coming in to work from the city that so
one women said to put sour milk on my
leg maybe it will go away because
started to swell and it was bad so we
hid managed to hit my mother's ring in
my mouth when we went into the
get out there not to get ugly the camps
so we gave her the ring cuz she brought
in a loaf of bread and a little cup of
sour milk so the three of us decided
what to do to put it on my leg and eat
it so we decide to have on my leg and
have to eat it now if we wouldn't be the
three of us we would would never survive
none of us would have made it because we
were watching out for one another put
out some trains to go farther towards
the west so we went to chance to have
another high monition factory somehow
the Russian armies came in too fast for
them and in 45 we were liberated and
they feeling it's a terrible feeling
Ryu and Kim you don't know what tomorrow
will bring but what made me go is I
thought my father was hiding in a
village with my little brother that
he'll survive there and I always I was
very very attached to my father I was it
was so the six-four it was a beautiful
person and a beautiful human being and I
thought he'll survive there and all of a
sudden you'll need me I'll I'll have to
help him he'll six like I am and he
needs help
this what made me go in order to it's
funny I'm thinking of it now that how I
split myself then it wasn't me there it
just wasn't me I was somebody else
it wasn't me and but unfortunately the
war ended we are actually afraid to
leave the place it was a very funny
feeling that we have were sitting
holding hands were afraid to go out
finally when we did go out we found
we'll find something terrible like
nothing and the natives went to friendly
either I went back home and to look for
my father so naturally they I came to
the city door already a few people and
they told me that my father Milo brother
was turned out of the Germans well
anyway so wasn't too good we had to get
out of Poland and we went back to the
land of Germany would you believe it
felt safe in Germany only because were
the Americans I suppose what they'll say
that I am and because I came to the
United States I met my husband here and
we have three children and every time
this is when I became pregnant with my
children I just like I woke up I got
terribly frightened and every time I I
thought of that the woman Rachel Rachel
Goldberg was her name
what happened her baby what she was very
close to having her baby and her face is
always fun to me what did he do to the
baby
what'd they do that Here I am and I did
have the children because I was said
that that's what Hitler would want - we
shouldn't have any children oh we
shouldn't we just disappear so my
children are named after my father my
brother my mother my sister they know
all this question me because you know
the old story where our grandparents
tell me but they were very curious very
bright children tell me about your
grandma about our grandparents how were
they like and what was your hometown
life I had like a panorama in front of
me constantly I could be in a room full
of people and if there was a time when I
was letting his conscious go I didn't I
didn't talk at all and I just just
couldn't believe it I just didn't talk
and then I was constantly talking after
the war because then I realized I was
afraid if I won't talk I'll see
everything and even not one now when I
vacuum I do some tedious house whole
thing I always cry obviously this I
could be it was with a hundred people
and if I sit quiet it's just like a
panorama with all that stuff coming to
mind nobody's left and we always my
house was always full of people because
all this time it was my grandmother was
with us so everybody was coming to my
house and so it always
think about those people when I'm always
afraid that I'll I don't have any
pictures of them then always wonder
about my little brother for my father
because the two of them were together
you always say how did they die what
happened it's some something you don't
forget the heart of it is every time I
see the newspaper now and with Nazis
somehow they it's just that it never
ends it's no end to it this is frayed to
me very much and I'm not trying to show
it to the children I want to scare them
then they men already grown people and
I'm scared
you